en el vídeo pasado empezamos a explorar
la idea de la curva
efe espero haber mencionado que quiere
decir inversión y ahorros pero en inglés
esto lo analizamos desde el punto de
vista de la inversión verdad empezamos
pensando esto en cómo la tasa de interés
real modificaba el nivel de inversión y
luego como con eso se cambiaba el nivel
de equilibrio de la producción real si
había un interés alto entonces había
baja inversión lo cual causaba un
equilibrio bajo entonces estábamos en
este escenario de por acá y por otro
lado si la tasa de interés era baja
entonces vamos a tener más inversión
planeada y eso va a llevar a un mayor
nivel de producción en equilibrio esta
de por acá
lo que voy a hacer en este vídeo el
pasado fue desde el punto de vista de
inversión pero lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es explorar exactamente la
misma relación en la misma curva pero
ahora desde un punto de vista de ahorros
en esta situación seguiremos teniendo la
misma gráfica solo que ahora en vez de
pensar como las tasas de interés cambian
el producto interno bruto vamos a pensar
como el producto interno bruto cambia la
tasa de interés real déjame desplazo
esto para acá
ahorita lo que vamos a hacer es volver a
escribir nuestro modelo de gastos del
producto interno bruto entonces el
ingreso agregado o bien el producto
interno bruto agregado es igual a y aquí
vamos a poner sus componentes es igual a
al gasto del consumidor que está en
función del ingreso disponible de yemen
usted que es el ingreso disponible
porque es el ingreso agregado menos los
impuestos más la inversión más la
inversión más los gastos del gobierno
más los gastos de gobierno aquí podría
sumar la exportación neta pero ahorita
por simplicidad vamos a suponer que
estamos en una economía cerrada para que
las cosas nos queden un poco más
sencillas vale bueno entonces lo que
quiero hacer ahorita es despejar de esta
ecuación la inversión entonces voy a
tener que restar esto de acá y esto de
acá de ambos lados de la ecuación y
entonces tendríamos que el ingreso
agregado menos el consumo el gasto del
consumidor agregado el total menos
el gasto gubernamental es igual a y en
el lado derecho nada más queda la
inversión la inversión planeada va queda
de este lado a la derecha bueno lo de la
izquierda está muy interesante porque
mira esta expresión bueno aquí tenemos
el ingreso total
- déjame asegurarme que que se entiende
bien que esto de aquí es el gasto del
consumidor porque parece minúscula pero
el consumo es con c mayúscula
entonces en el lado izquierdo tenemos el
ingreso agregado total menos el gasto
del consumidor menos el gasto del
gobierno
entonces fíjate podemos pensar en toda
esta expresión simplemente como el
ahorro agregada entonces podemos
pensarlo como los ahorros y recuerda
como lo hemos visto en otros vídeos
si una persona ahorra entonces eso acaba
en un banco y el banco lo puede prestar
o bien podemos pensar directamente que
lo que se ahorra se reinvierte eso está
muy bueno verdad entonces el ahorro va a
ser igual a la inversión y por eso es la
curva y ese porque miren el modelo de
gastos el ahorro y la inversión es
exactamente lo mismo y entonces podemos
pensar esta curva de dos formas
distintas podemos pensar en términos de
la inversión o bien del ahorro
al pensarlo de esta forma de acá
entonces la perspectiva es un poco
distinta porque mira desde este punto de
vista entonces podemos preguntarnos qué
va a suceder si aumenta el producto
interno bruto o sea mira si tenemos un
producto interno bruto no sé
supongamos más bien pongámosle que el
producto interno bruto aumenta para ver
qué pasa entonces la función de consumo
va a aumentar no va a aumentar demasiado
en realidad va a aumentar lo que aumente
esta expresión de acá pero multiplicado
asumiendo el modelo lineal por la
propensión marginal al consumo que es
menor que uno que es algo entre 0 y 1
entonces esto si va a aumentar pero
menos que el cambio de iu y ahorita en
este modelo estamos pensando que no
habrá ningún cambio en el gasto
gubernamental entonces si el gasto total
agregado o más bien si el ingreso total
agregado aumenta entonces los ahorros
van a aumentar suponiendo que el gasto
del gobierno es constante
así los ahorros
ahorros aumentan ok luego si los ahorros
aumentan pues qué sucede eso quiere
decir que hay más fondos prestables hay
más dinero para prestar y que hay más
dinero para prestar pues que es usted en
general con cualquier cosa cuando hay
más de eso entonces su precio disminuye
verdad cuál es el precio es la tasa de
interés donde la tasa de interés
disminuye así si el ahorro aumenta las
tasas de interés reales van a bajar de
este modo si el producto interno bruto
es alto la tasa interés va a ser baja y
una vez más viendo el producto interno
bruto como la variable independiente
entonces un alto nivel de ahorros baja
las tasas de interés también pasa lo
mismo al revés si tienes un menor un
menor nivel de ingresos entonces esta
expresión de aquí también va a disminuir
no tanto verdad no tanto como el ayer de
nuevo por lo de la propensión marginal
al consumo que es un factor menor que
uno como lo vimos por acá arriba verdad
como lo vimos justo por acá así en total
el ahorro va a disminuir el gasto el
gobierno otra vez es constante en esta
situación los ahorros disminuyen y qué
sucede en esta situación qué pasa si hay
menos dinero
hay menos fondos que se puedan prestar
bueno en este caso como disminuye la
oferta de un bien ese ese bien aumenta
de precio como el precio de tomar
prestado es la tasa de interés de este
modo las tasas de interés van a aumentar
entonces es lo mismo que aparece aquí
arriba verdad si tenemos un ingreso
agregado menor entonces los fondos
prestados disminuyen y así las tasas de
interés real aumentan otra vez
exactamente en la misma curva de la
curva y ese pero ahora aprendimos dos
lecciones número uno es que se llama
iese porque es de inversión y ahorros y
en el modelo de gastos son la misma cosa
el ahorro de alguien en la inversión de
otra persona y dos vistos desde el punto
de vista de la inversión podemos pensar
que r cambia h pero ahora lo estamos
viendo de otra forma ya modifica los
ahorros y los ahorros modifican el
interés es exactamente lo mismo desde
dos puntos de vista